au portugal nouveau soulèvement
militaire les putschistes paraissent
avoir la situation bien en main ils
annoncent la formation d'un gouvernement
provisoire et des élections libres
campagne électorale nous rendre compte
des interventions de monsieur chaban
delmas à nancy giscard d'estaing à
rennes mitterrand aaron et royer à
marseille football le bayern de munich
et l'atlético de madrid se sont
qualifiés pour la finale de la coupe
d'europe de football en battant hier
soir oups est debout la peste et le
celtic de glasgow
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour portugal dans un communiqué
publié ce matin à 11 heures à lisbonne
le commandement du mouvement des forces
armées c'est à dire des putschistes
annoncent qu'ils contrôlent presque
entièrement la situation et que le
ministre de l'armée est entré en
pourparlers avec les rebelles est
également que gouvernement provisoire a
été formé qui restera en fonction 10 les
putschistes jusqu'à l'organisation
d'élections libres
c'est donc quarante jours après la
première mutinerie qui avait avorté
qu'un nouveau soulèvement d'envergure
celui ci a ébranlé ce matin le portugal
le profond malaise perceptible depuis
longtemps dans la vie politique
portugaise a abouti à 5h ce matin à une
crise aiguë les chars ont pris position
à lisbonne un émetteur de radio a été
occupée la situation n'est pas encore
tout à fait clair mais l'impression qui
prévaut est que ce soulèvement a été
mieux organisés que le précédent et
qu'il a donc plus de chances de réussir
un rappel maintenant des événements qui
ont précédé le soulèvement d'aujourd'hui
et qui explique également dans une
certaine mesure les raisons de ce
soulèvement
le mouvement des forces armées rebelles
au régime du premier ministre marcelo
caetano et du président de la république
du portugal l'amiral américo tomaz
installé donc ce matin avant l'aube ses
troupes aux points stratégiques de
lisbonne issu de l'armée de terre le
mouvement semble avoir été rejoint par
la marine lisbonne est calme ce matin la
circulation est réduite beaucoup de
boutiques de magasins de banques sont
restées fermées
les rebelles qui se sont emparés de la
radio 10 bonnes ont demandé à la
population de rester chez elle cette
fois ci la rébellion semble avoir les
choses bien en main
le ministre de l'intérieur celui de la
guerre celui de l'armée ont été arrêtés
dans un communiqué les rebelles ont
annoncé la formation de
mon provisoire qui restera en place
jusqu'à ce que tiennent les élections
libres au portugal les libertés
démocratiques vont être rétabli une
longue page de l'histoire du portugal
est ainsi tournée
le premier changement était intervenu à
la mort de salazar qui avait tenu ce
petit pays neuf millions d'habitants
dans sa poigne de fer pendant trente ans
à force d'autorité d'intransigeance il
avait su conserver une façade calme un
pays qui consacrait déjà depuis de
nombreuses années la moitié de son
budget entretenir des guerres coloniales
outre-mer au mozambique en angola en
guinée-bissau apparue d'abord comme plus
libéral monsieur marcelo caetano n'a pas
réussi à sortir son pays du bourbier
une grande partie de la jeunesse devait
aller lutter contre la guérilla
cinquante cinq mille hommes servait en
angola soixante mille au mozambique
27000 en guinée portugaise le service
militaire obligatoire dure deux à quatre
ans alors une grande partie des hommes
plutôt que de servir à réprimer les
mouvements luttant pour leurs
indépendances en afrique préférèrent
s'exiler quitter ce pays pauvre saigner
à blanc par la guerre sans avenir pour
eux pour trouver des emplois mieux
rémunérés
ailleurs en europe et puis il y a deux
mois eu lieu la banque spinola ce
général portugais héros des guerres
coloniales écrivait dans un livre
intitulé le portugal et son avenir
nous n'y arriverons pas par la force
organisons l'autodétermination dans les
provinces d'afrique et mettons en place
un système fédéral qu'il mettrait sur un
pied d'égalité avec la métropole
il était alors limogé de son poste en
réserve en quelques chiffres
mais vous n'avez plus de fonctions
militaires précise rien n'indique que le
général spinola soit derrière à
l'origine ou alliée à la rébellion
éclaté ce matin son livre c'est sûr aura
pourtant décomplexée de nombreux
opposants au régime
les heures qui viennent vont sans doute
nous renseigner
une dépêche qui nous parvient à
l'instant annonce que le mouvement des
forces armées c'est à dire les
putschistes à lisbonne un an ce qu'ils
ont obtenu la reddition du gouvernement
kaiten d'autres nouvelles sûrement à
propos de la situation conjugale au
cours de ce journal passons maintenant
aux nouvelles de france la hausse des
prix la hausse des prix a été en mars de
1,2 pour cent après 1,7 pour cent en
janvier et 1,3 pour cent au mois de
février annonce non officiellement ce
qui fait si mes calculs sont bons 4,2
pour cent depuis le début de l'année en
trois mois soit un rythme annuel de
hausse de l'ordre de 17% élection à la
présidence de la république maintenant
chaque jour ou presque apporte son
sondage dont on peut rappeler à propos
de son âge que ce ne sont pas des
prévisions mais bel et bien des
photographies de l'opinion à un moment
donné et seulement à ce moment là
aujourd'hui notre confrère le figaro
publie une enquête de la sofres sur les
intentions de vote tel quel était le 22
avril c'est-à-dire il ya trois jours
monsieur mitterrand recueille 42% de ses
intentions de vote soit un gain de 2%
monsieur giscard d'estaing reste à 28%
monsieur jacques chaban delmas le suit à
24% -2 %
notons également 4% d'intentions de vote
pour monsieur royer -1 1% et 2% pour les
candidats restant les principaux
candidats ont poursuivi hier leur tour
de france il était à nancy rennes et
rouen
en vérité la puissance de la france
aujourd'hui elle est faite sur la base
suivante taux de croissance
oui qui fait cette croissance qui la
paye et qui en reçoit les fruits et la
réponse vient aussitôt lorsque l'on sait
que les travailleurs français les
salariés et les agriculteurs sont ceux
qui supportent aujourd'hui la plus forte
hausse des prix au sein du marché commun
on nous avait annoncé il ya quelques
années 3% ç'a été cinq pour cent on nous
annonce et 6% cédé 10%
on est passé à 10% à monter à 12 % nous
sommes à 15 et du moment qu'on nous dit
qu'elle attendait les dix huit 18 %
d'inflation
cela représente une formidable quantité
de fausses monnaies répandu à l'heure
actuelle dans notre économie
et chacun sait que l'inflation si c'est
un impôt pour les petits patrimoines
c'est une subvention pour les grandes
fortunes
alors le pouvoir actuel s'est installé
dans l'inflation cela ne le gênait pas
il s'en est accommodé se contentant de
dire il me suffira d'avoir un train
galopant qui galope un peu moins vite
que mes plus puissant voisin
je veux dire l'allmend le pari de
monsieur giscard d'estaing est en manque
et les millions et les millions de
travailleurs et je pense surtout aux
ménagères qui se rendent sur le marché
savent bien qu'avec un salaire qui lui a
pris du retard et je vais vous en
parlait il convient maintenant d'acheter
des produits de première nécessité
frappé par un lourd impôt qui s'appelle
la tva c'est à dire un impôt indirect
qui frappe également le pauvre et le
riche ce qui veut dire inégalement car
le pauvre a les mêmes besoins que le
riche pour sa nourriture et pour
vêtements ce qui veut dire qu'en vérité
ménagères apprend tous les jours que les
statistiques les indices la façon dont
on bâtit tous ces calculs ne correspond
en rien à la réalité
si la moyenne française est de 15% la
ménagère femmes du travailleurs payent
davantage qu'un 6000 personnes hier soir
à la salle omnisports de rennes où
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
accompagné par monsieur christian bonnet
et jean luc annaix te met son troisième
et dernier meeting de la journée après
le mans et brest
monsieur giscard d'estaing a abordé
quelques thèmes essentiels tels que
l'emploi l'europe la sécurité la justice
les problèmes régionaux souvent
applaudis par une large majorité de la
salle
monsieur giscard d'estaing était
également chahutées par quelques
dizaines de contestataires
cette élection présidentielle et je vous
laisse extrait pousser votre structure
pendant quelques minutes pour vous fait
réaliser combien il est peu repris par
la salle
car vous êtes la minorité de la
révolution bedian la révolution opposent
matin dans la majorité des travailleurs
et les travailleurs travailleuses
françaises n'ont absolument ni le désir
et organes apportant leur soutien
le problème se pose à l'heure actuelle
la france n'est pas du tout celui là
c'est de savoir qui elle va choisir le 5
mai le 19 mai prochain et non pas dans
quelques extrémismes de pacotille on
voudrait la faire verser après quoi
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing s'est
attaché à définir devant le public
breton la majorité nouvelle qui souhaite
constituer la nouvelle majorité
françaises
c'est une majorité qui maintiendra qui
prolongera tout ce qui a été entrepris
mais qu'il oubliera à des dimensions
nouvelles
cette nouvelle majorité qui doit elle
comprend elle va comprendre la totalité
de celles et de ceux qui en bretagne
comme ailleurs ont apporté son
défaillance leur soutien à l'action du
président pompidou
mais puisque nous sommes dans une
circonstance nouvelle
il faut donner le temps de cette
majorité devienne une majorité nouvelle
et dont
et donc quelle chose à tous ceux qui ont
des propositions nouvelles affaires une
contribution apportée à la politique de
la france et c'est cette majorité
nouvelle qui doit apparaître dans les
urnes le 5 mai et le 19 mai prochain à
l'issue de la réunion quelques
échauffourées se sont produites
il y a eu deux blessés parmi les
contestataires nancy lot de la foire
exposition était archi comble hier soir
c'est une salle jeunes des étudiants et
des ouvriers des ouvriers des aciéries
des mines et du textile venus de toute
la lorraine jamais à nancy une réunion
politique n'avait rassemblé autant de
monde
le thème il hier soir la hausse des prix
je ne propose pas comme certains
programmes ou des perspectives dire à
jacques chaban delmas mais un contrat
non rien ne regardons pas la france font
des yeux pour l'hypnotiser et par
l'action et la volonté rétablissons la
confiance la confiance économique et
monétaire plus confiance à promener ce
qui veut dire mieux
les sondages d'opinion qui n'a plus
confiance en ceux qui sont chargés de
lui maintenir une valeur stable au
établir la confiance c'est réparé les
dégâts causés par l'inflation s'est
assuré une rémunération réelle et
honnête allez pas me brûler celle-ci
vrai la chasse aux pièces d'or aux
oeuvres d'art ou aux terrains à
construire c'est le plus soumettre à
l'impôt sur le revenu des petits
salaires que seuls l'appelation a confié
en apparence c'est assurer au revenu
minimum des chefs de familles des
personnes âgées une garantie automatique
pour la hausse des prix
deuxième thème de la soirée
l'indépendance l'indépendance de
l'europe mais aussi l'indépendance de la
france c'est le nom à toutes les
hégémonies n'oublions pas que
l'indépendance de la france
c'est la garantie de la liberté de
chacune et de chacun des français et des
françaises et ce qui est certain c'est
qu'à politique de la france pour la
france pour les français ne peut se
faire ne peut se décider ni à washington
ni à moscou mais seulement à paris
j'envoyais n'a pas fait salle comble
hier soir à marseille la ville de
monsieur gaston defferre et comme à
rennes nancy montpellier
c'est pendant près d'une heure et demie
que l'ancien ministre a de nouveau
expliqué toutes les idées maîtresses de
son programme en particulier son plan
social
premier chapitre la protection de la
famille cellule de base de la société
père de cinq enfants jean royer a
réaffirmé son opposition à l'avortement
deuxième chapitre l'éducation ancien
instituteur jean royer à réclamer un
enseignement moins théorique et plus
pratique grâce à des stages dans des
ateliers des usines ou des entreprises
enfin dernier chapitre du plan social
l'emploi
le maire de tours a parlé en particulier
du problème des émigrés il faut d'abord
avoir une idée de l' équilibre entre le
nombre de travailleurs étrangers et le
nombre de travailleurs manuels français
et pour cela payer ce qu'ils font payer
pour les métiers pénibles depuis le
cantonnier l'éboueur le terrassier celui
qui manipule une grue
celui qui participe l'eau ferraillage et
au boisage dans les chantiers du
bâtiment
celui qui travaille dans la mine et
celui qui s'usent plus rapidement que
les autres dans des métiers de point
même de recherche qui sont
particulièrement éprouvant rémunérer
mieux ces métiers pénibles et réorienter
une bonne partie de la jeunesse vers les
métiers manuels en infléchissant
certains préjugés des familles contre
les soi-disant métier il faut
réhabiliter la côte bleue face au col
blanc eh bien nous revenons maintenant à
la situation au portugal je vous
rappelle la nouvelle que je vous donnais
il ya un instant le mouvement des forces
armées annonce qu'il a obtenu la
reddition du gouvernement caetano les
forces armées sont acclamés nil agence
france presse dans les rues de lisbonne
sur la grande place une foule
considérable crient victoire victoire
sur la grande place de la capitale ou
non
confrère jean françois chauvel se
trouvait hier soir encore il vient de
rentrer et jean françois chauvel vous
avez eu ce matin votre équipe que vous
avez laissé là bas qui fait un reportage
pour le magazine la troisième chaîne 52
que vous dirigez vous avez vu ce matin
votre équipe au téléphone
quelles sont les nouvelles que vous avez
pu avoir et bien c'est effectivement ce
mouvement les capitaines dont on parlait
beaucoup depuis quelques temps qui est à
l'origine du mouvement puisque dominique
de roux avait rencontré hier soir un de
ses capitaines et il a été réveillé à
4h30 ce matin par le même capitaine qui
lui a dit ça y est c'est parti
alors il s'est tout de suite précipité
dans la rue pour aller voir ce qui se
passait il s'est rendu tout de suite au
domicile du général spinola jaspiner là
comme vous le savez à il y a trois mois
sortait un livre qui a fait scandale
ce livre consacré au futur du portugal
proposer expliqué d'abord une évidence
c'est à dire que la guerre que mènent
les portugais en afrique ne peut pas
être gagnée par des moyens militaires et
faisaient une proposition c'est à dire
transformer lempire portugais en une
fédération d'états autonome
le tout étant confirmée par l'auto
détermination des populations ce livre a
fait scandale
mais il a tiré à deux cent mille
exemplaires en trois mois ce qui est le
plus fort tirage jamais observée dans la
littérature portugaise alors peut-on
dire à ce propos
nogueira spinola et derrière le putsch
de ce matin eh bien oui il est derrière
plus exactement les putschistes se
réclament de lui car dominique de roux
est allé donc au déficit général spinale
à la rue où est la maison gerra spinale
a été barrée par des troupes par des
soldats il a parlé avec le capitaine
commandant ces soldats qui lui a dit oui
le generali libre oui nous sommes avec
lui
oui le général est parti pour
l'état-major donc c'est à l'état majeur
que ça se passe en ce moment
ce qui est intéressant à souligner dans
cette affaire c'est que le général
spinola qui est un héros pour l'armée
portugaise
il a été décoré au mois d'octobre
dernier par le président de la
république de la plus haute distinction
militaire portugaise jamais accordé un
militaire depuis 50 ans lors de la tour
et de l'épée le général spinola et au
fond d'accord avec le président du
conseil caetano qui est actuellement
démissionnaire je sais pas si les
démissionnaires mais nous allons voir
car en fait les ultras s'étaient
regroupés autour du président de la
république l'amiral américo thomass qui
est un monsieur de 80 2 ans et keita
nous avait été obligé de s'incliner
devant le prix dans la république car
vous savez au portugal c'est comme en
france le pouvoir appartient au
président de la république c'est lui qui
nomme le président du conseil qui n'est
pas responsable devant le parlement
alors de ces petits strass est
intéressante voir maintenant si spinola
y caetano s'entendent pour justement
transformer la le climat politique au
portugal et de définir de nouveaux
objectifs pour la politique d'outre-mer
a bien mais peut-être nous en
reparlerons ce soir puisque vous revenez
pour notre édition de 19h45
merci maintenant la suite de l'actualité
en france le smic relevé le 1er mai le
ministère du travail annonce que
l'augmentation pourrait être supérieure
à l'indexation sur la hausse des prix et
atteindre 4% ce qui porterait le salaire
mensuel pour 40 heures à un peu plus de
1000 francs la cgt la cfdt réclame 12
100 francs pour 40 heures de travail
une nouvelle hausse du smic est prévue
pour le 1er juillet réduction du prix
des transports maritimes et aériens
entre le continent et la corse à partir
de samedi cette réduction de 13 à 20%
annoncée par monsieur olivier guichard
intervient à la suite du récent voyage
encore de monsieur pierre messmer mais
cette réduction n'est pas valable
pendant les grandes vacances sauf pour
les résidents corses
autre décision le gouvernement financera
un programme de 12 millions de francs
pour remettre en état le chemin de fer
coke
le bayern de munich rencontrera
l'atlético de madrid le 15 mai à
bruxelles en finale de la coupe d'europe
et au vue des deux matchs d'hier soir
munich partira légèrement favori
l'équipe de beckenbauer et müller après
avoir débuté prudemment devant espèce de
budapest a réussi en effet un match très
convaincant au stade olympique de munich
devant 80000 spectateurs
le bayern a ouvert le score à la 36e
minute à la suite de cette action
confuse devant les blues brad
torstensson à tirer et marquer bayern ne
va ensuite multiplié les attaques et en
deuxième mi temps alors que müller
menace constamment la défense hongroise
horvat marque contre son camp
gerd müller le meilleur buteur européen
va d'ailleurs inscrire à son tour un but
après avoir échoué ici au ralenti devant
le gardien hongrois et sur le corner qui
suit muller exploite une erreur du gold
us fait 3-0 paume unique au ralenti le
tir de muller
venez voir le ballon passe au ras des
poteaux
à madrid le service d'ordre était
renforcée l'arbite monsieur cheikh s'est
montré intransigeant
les incidents du match aller ne se sont
pas reproduits heureusement et
l'atlético de madrid a prouvé qu'il
savait aussi jouer au foot
voici d'ailleurs son premier but réussi
par garate à la 75e minute madrid
l'emporté 2 à 0 adélard d'autres cette
action va marquer à son tour un du
splendid et mabri pourra également la
finale avant de terminer les deux
principales nouvelle de la matinée la
hausse des prix en france au mois de
mars elle a été de 1 2% la statistique
vient d'être publié après 1 7% en
janvier et 1 3% en février à à lisbonne
les militaires putschistes ont annoncé
qu'ils avaient obtenu la démission du
gouvernement caytan d'autres
informations peut-être dans le courant
de l'après-midi ou en tout cas à 19h45
merci de votre attention d'après midi